[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8
politique une édition consacrée en
grande partie à l'après primaire de la
droite et du centre françois fillon va
donc était désigné candidat à l'issue du
scrutin qui s'est déroulé fin novembre
et c'est une toute autre campagne qui
débute comment va-t-il organiser ses
troupes son programme
nous allons en parler avec nos invités
ils sont cinq
aujourd'hui alain schmitz le responsable
de l'organisation de la primaire dans
les yvelines bonsoir bonsoir également
un karl olive conseiller départemental
les républicains maire de poissy anciens
soutiens dans leurs jupettes bonsoir
benassaya mer les républicains de bois
d'arcy
bonsoir vous vous étiez un soutien de
bruno le maire suzanne blanc bonsoir
soutien dès le départ je le précise
alain de françois fillon
vous êtes également maire-adjointe de
montigny le bretonneux l est républicain
et puis bonsoir flore assabah vous êtes
la présidente des jeunes républicains
est du département des yvelines
ancien soutien de nicolas sarkozy et
nous reviendrons aussi sur le reste de
l'actualité politique dans le
département des derniers jours n'ont pas
débuté par cette actualité nous
enregistrons cette émission vendredi
matin et hier soir vous l'avez suivi
j'imagine et cette annonce de françois
hollande son renoncement il ne sera pas
candidat pour un nouveau mandat et on va
commencer par un tour de table et avoir
votre sentiment sur ce renoncement de
françois hollande
karl olive on peut pas dire que ce soit
une très grande surprise la surprise
c'est cette annonce à tout petit peu
prématuré puisqu'il reste encore un peu
plus de six mois de mandat et de ce
quinquennat
je crois qu'on n'est plus aujourd'hui
dans la famille réunie de droite a à se
focaliser sur le projet plutôt que celui
de nos adversaires
après je pense que l'histoire aussi
parce qu'on voit ce qui s'est passé
pendant la primaire avec l'élimination
de nicolas sarkozy l'élimination de
d'alain juppé on est dans un espèce de
voile à de nouvel élan et il faut
impérativement écouter celles et ceux
qui vont voter
la primaire de droite et du centre l'a
parfaitement montré je pense que ça
c'était très fort qui est envoyé par les
français
suzanne blanc ce départ de françois
hollande finalement c'est la logique des
choses
c'est pas forcément la logique des
choses mais c'était mon plaisir à lire
voilà ça fait surtout un grand
changement dans la dans l'horizon
politique parce que du coup aucun des
anciens entre guillemets président ne
seront présents voilà et puis il ya
sûrement mûrement réfléchie bon ça a
pressé c'est son histoire mais
effectivement je suis plus focalisés sur
la suite et le désir de réussir et de
faire triompher les couleurs de notre
famille ici présentes
fo qui avait soutenu nicolas sarkozy
françois hollande n'ira pas non plus
écoutez j'ai trouvé moi personnellement
même émouvant françois hollande hier on
a été dans la petite larmichette à
l'oeil c'est une des seules décisions de
son mandat qu'on pourra salué
unanimement 8 français sur 10 qui sont
ce matin
satisfait de cette décision l'euro -
huit sur dix a fait 80 % c'est bon on va
y aura touché par le disque ou non en
france
en france on aime bien les renoncements
on a bien des regrets on a créé les
discours pathétique n'aime pas trop le
succès story j'ai l'impression ce pays
mais sinon bah je me souviens simplement
de du slogan de françois hollande en
2012 il voulait réenchanter la france et
ça se termine dans une pagaille
monumentale que la page est tournée et
nous on est focalisé sur sur la victoire
de françois fillon a admis s'agit de
cette victoire malgré tout françois
fillon et à s'inscrit aussi dans la
logique des choses après après le
quinquennat aussi on imagine que le
choix des français a aussi été motivé
par ce qui s'est passé pendant cinq ans
c'est certain moi je pense que le départ
de françois hollande il est inéluctable
il s'est appliqué à lui même le constat
d'échec que tout un chacun tenait sur la
politique il avait mises en oeuvre
depuis son élection
donc voilà dont acte sans émotion
particulière
et comme les uns et les autres on se
projette dans l'avenir un avenir
nettement plus serré depuis
l'organisation des primaires visant à
l'ajustement à présent de cet avenir cet
avenir de la droite du sang
à l'issue de cette primaire ce scrutin
qui s'est déroulé et qui a rassemblé à
travers la france plus de 4 millions de
français
sans vous contrôlerez le chiffre mais
ses 166 mille dans le département
exactement soit égal de progression
entre les entre les deux tours entre les
deux tours de scrutin qui s'est plutôt
bien passé on va y venir aussi mais à la
question qui se pose c'est ce
rassemblement aujourd'hui est ce que les
choses vont dans ce sens et on va poser
la question aux anciens soutiens des
différents candidats philippe benassaya
vous avez soutenu bruno le maire avec un
peu de déception résultat final oui j'ai
soutenu bruno le maire d'abord parce que
il m'a semblé que dans cette compétition
il fallait un peu avoir des têtes
nouvelles
son parcours m'a beaucoup plu son
programme également son désir de
renouveau c'est pas facile faire leur
nid dans notre famille politique c'est
jamais facile
quelques ce que ce soit au niveau local
au niveau au niveau national maintenant
dans une élection
présidentielle il suffit pas d'être le
meilleur ou le bon élève il suffit aussi
séduire et là je crois que c'est là où
le bât a blessé c'est que dans une
compétition aussi médiatique
la séduction est très importante et la
proximité aussi il a manqué pas mal de
choses dans cette élection mais je crois
que bruno a pris date
et ensuite on verra comment ça se
passera mais je suis très content
d'avoir fait cette campagne est très
content également aujourd'hui de
soutenir françois fillon tiendra le
rassemblement sera aujourd'hui justement
vous êtes satisfait de ce qui est alors
premièrement d'abord je suis très
satisfait l'organisation des primaires
dans les yvelines
vraiment ça a été quelque chose
d'extraordinaire et et félicitations
alors c'est vrai que ça s'est très très
bien passé deuxièmement je suis d'autant
plus étonné par notre capacité à étonner
c'est un bien grand mot mais étonné par
notre capacité de rassemblement que
j'étais très peu favorable à une
primaire ouverte je suis pas un grand
fan de la primaire ouverte
on sait qu'il fallait peut-être faire
une primaire fermée mais ça parlera
peut-être une autre fois mais c'est vrai
que compte tenu de mes réticences je
suis très très très satisfait
aujourd'hui de cette organisation et de
cette capacité qu'ont à deux de se
rassembler sur cette question primaires
ouvertes justement un flora sa bague on
a souvent entendu nicolas sarkozy dire
qu'il n'y était pas forcément favorable
puisque ça pouvait amener aussi des
électeurs et un vote anti nicolas
sarkozy sarkozy écoute et oui c'est
quelque chose qui fait débat après si
c'est si c'est une primaire fermée ça
s'appelle pas une primaire c'est une
consultation interne j'ai envie de dire
une primaire c'était aussi justement
pour qu'il y ait des sympathisants pas
forcément adhérents de notre mouvement
mais qu'ils puissent donner leur avis
sur le futur président de la république
donc je vais envie de dire c'était
compliqué de faire une primaire fermée
en réalité se règle rien le fond quand
on voit les américains il faut dire du
marché les démocraties le primergy 2015
on peut pas se passe plutôt que de
réellement comparer aux états unis
forcément satisfaits de leur candidat
orignal et ça c'est autre chose en tout
cas sur les aujourd'hui les listings ont
été envoyés en tout cas sur la victoire
de françois fillon votre regard vous
êtes pleinement engagé aux côtés de
françois fillon
est complètement derrière françois
fillon aujourd'hui de toute manière
c'est un soutien qui est cohérent de par
le programme de nicolas sarkozy donc
c'est quelque chose qui coule de sens et
au niveau des militants on n'a pas de
problème de ce point de vue là on est
tous unis derrière françois fillon et
ont fait bloc
car on sait que c'est lui qui va porter
nos idées aux présidentielles karl olive
mêmes sentiments vous qui avez soutenu
alain juppé oui jo je rejoins
départements qui étaient vraiment
appliqués derrière alain juppé à
d'ailleurs je le précise parce qu'il y
avait plus de soutiens parmi les et mur
vert alain juppé que la france ont filmé
il ya quelque chose qui s'appelle des
convictions je pense que c'est important
de pouvoir s'engager sans attendre
l'arrivée du tiercé pour donner lors des
shows ça me paraît important est ici
autour de cette table
wilfrid vous avez des gens qui ont qui
sont plein de conviction et qui sont
pétri de convictions philippe a soutenu
depuis le départ bruno le maire flora a
soutenu et appuyé par nicolas sarkozy
suzanne françois fillon et et votre
serviteur
alain juppé je pense que c'est important
puis après faut pas se tromper de combat
la primaire flora viens de le dire
c'était une compétition ce n'était pas
un combat et aujourd'hui il faut une
capacité de rassemblement qui
effectivement ne s'apprend pas forcément
dans le dictionnaire et la légitimité
porté par les français à l'endroit de
françois fillon doit nous permettre plus
que jamais de nous rassembler et à ce
titre là moi je voudrais aussi féliciter
le président la chemise sur le
département des yvelines pour pour sa
faculté à avoir organisé de main de
maître cette organisation c'est une
première
parce que philippe a raison c'est pas un
exercice naturel on l'a jamais vu dans
notre famille politique
ce mouvement plutôt bonapartiste il
fallait s'approprier un candidat
naturellement il n'existait pas sur le
papier
sur le terrain les personnes ont montré
maintenant je pense que les charges à
françois fillon et à toutes ses
sensibilités différent de pouvoir se
retrouver et il ya encore du travail
parce que c'est pas gagné moi je pense
notamment aux classes modestes pense
notamment aux classes populaires qui
paradoxalement se sont déplacés ce
week-end elle ne l'avait jamais fait et
ça c'est des gens que lesquels il faudra
compter comme d'ailleurs les trois
millions six cent mille chômeurs ils
peuvent faire basculer une élection
donc là on vous entend rien une union
mais malgré tout va y avoir des
discussions autour des différents
programmes et là ça aussi en
on va y venir un jeu mais vous ne
regrettez pas votre venue ce matin tout
le monde salue le travail d'organisation
de la primaire si à tous et à toutes
cette primaire était difficile organisée
elle été difficile parce que c'était un
exercice qui nous semble être périlleux
puisque nous ne l'avions jamais réalisé
auparavant
d'où cette incertitude relayé d'une
certaine inquiétude
j'allais dire je parlais de tous mes
bureaux de mes présidents de bureaux de
vote alors c'est surtout un élan
extraordinaire qui a su être donnée
parce que nous avons su rassembler 264
présidente obtenir donc mon bureau de
vote à travers le département des
yvelines est mobilisé quelques 15 cents
militants qui ont servi évidemment
d'assesseurs duran duran chacun des deux
tours de la primaire donc un exercice
difficile
le succès est bien entendu au
rendez-vous succès d'ailleurs qui nous a
surpris puisque nous étions presque en
manque et d' enveloppe et de bulletins
heureusement qu'il y avait j'allais dire
les bulletins et enveloppes nécessaire
au second tour qui avait été donnée à
chacun des présidents
mais même dans les villes comme
versailles par exemple ou des deux
heures ont sonné le tocsin pour me dire
attention nous risquons de ne plus avoir
de bulletins donc il a fallu venir au
secours de des présidents qui
rencontrent et j'allais dire un grand
succès moi ce qui m'a frappé si vous
voulez dans cette affluence c'est le
stoïcisme j'allais dire de tous les
participants qui n'ont pas hésité à
tendre parfois près d'une heure et demie
avant de pouvoir voter vous vous
rappelez que le dimanche du premier tour
le climat était particulièrement mauvais
donc c'était il faisait froid et il
pleuvait et bien moi c'est ce qui m'a
vraiment impressionné c'est à dire cette
volonté du peuple de droite de vouloir
s'exprimer à travers cette élection tout
à fait novatrice puisque c'était
vraiment une première pour non seulement
pour la classe politique mais également
pour notre pour toute la population
illinoise est également un point
important c'est qu'on a tout autant voté
en milieu rural qu'en milieu urbain
je pense que c'est une spécificité
également yvelinoise la mobilisation a
été très forte mais je pense aussi qu'il
ya eu un engagement extrêmement fort de
tous les élus et dans des départements
comme dans le reste de la france en
françois fillon est arrivé largement en
tête on va mettre de côté un peu cette
primaire pour se projeter et parler de
cette union de cette nouvelle campagne
qui va débuter il ya tout de même
quelques voix un petit peu qui se font
entendre différentes lui dit les jeunes
udi par exemple ils sont un peu plus
d'une centaine les responsables des
jeunes udi à travers la france à
soutenir aujourd'hui emmanuel macron je
vous propose d'écouter l'un d'entre eux
là c'est marc lerouge c'est le
responsable de la fédération yvelines
des jeunes udi ziv écoutez le il ya eu
des réactions très excessive très
excessive à cette tribune
certains nous expliquant que nous avions
décidé de quitter mini moi
personnellement j'ai pas décider de
toutes les niches très à l'aise dans ma
famille politique
aujourd'hui les idées formulées par
contre fillon et le roi il a répété
encore ce matin à dire qu' il ne
voudrait pas sur ce programme c'est ce
qu'il a dit et j'ai même envie de dire
il a raison il a raison il a été élu
pour faire un programme donc il a
entièrement raison
maintenant nous par rapport aux idées
sur l'europe aujourd'hui françois fillon
était absolument inaudible c'est un
sujet qui n'intéresse pas sur l'écologie
ça ne l'intéresse pas sur les questions
sociétales
ça ne m'intéresse mais alors ça va pas
du tout dans le sens où nous voulons
aller
et aujourd'hui emmanuel macron fait les
propositions ce que je note simplement
c'est que quand il a quitté le
gouvernement
on lui dit et le président de l'udps et
a dit que j'en avais occasion a parlé
avec frau qui était de centre-gauche que
nous étions du centre-droit que nous
allions vocation avait parlé et à faire
bouger les lignes politiquement suzanne
blanch votre réaction vous qui soutenez
françois fillon depuis le début on a
entendu ce jeune responsable de faim ce
responsable des jeunes udi pardon qui
est plutôt critique envers certains
points du programme par exemple et qui
appelle à soutenir
normalement quand moi ce que j'ai ce que
je retiens surtout c'est que dès lundi
jean christophe lagarde rencontré
françois fillon je ne sais pas ce qu'ils
se sont dit mais quand on est jeune
c'est vrai qu'on est peut-être un peu
moins comme on dit en obéissant mais
disciplinés peut-être qu'ils vont
attendre quelques directives avant de se
lancer à fond
je peux comprendre aussi qu'il ait des
choses qui les hearts peut-être ou qu'il
est qu'ils ne satisfont pas mais voilà
il faut donner un petit peu de temps le
temps puis les choses devraient rentrer
dans l'ordre sans pour autant que
françois fillon reviennent entièrement
sur son programme il a été élu malgré
tout sur un programme bien défini
on peut faire bouger quelques lignes on
ne peut pas tout faire bouger non plus
sinon c'est sinon ça n'aurait pas été la
peine que t'en demande se donne le mal
d'aller voter comme le disait à la cahc
monkam entourent jeu je félicite avec
toute l'amitié que je lui porte
parce que j'avais pas encore fait en
plus et parce que c'est vrai qu'il a été
un président de l'oeil tout à fait voilà
oui tout à fait à l'écouté tout à fait
comment dire respectueux du fait que mon
voile à lui de ne pas prendre position
ça a été le cas et c'est et c'était très
bien voilà donc un savant s'en prendre à
des ajustements à ses programmes va
devoir un petit peu changé et évolué
pour justement peut-être récupérer ces
voix qui commence à s'éloigner comme
celle des jeunes udi d'une partie des
jeunes u des jeux partage pas forcément
ce que ce que vient de nous dire suzanne
sur un point sur le fait que les jeunes
ne voterai pas forcément comme comme on
souhaiterait qu'il le fasse c'est pas
exactement ce que ce samedi mais c'est
un petit peu le sentiment ce que je
pense que justement ce week-end et les
deux derniers week-ends et ce qui vient
de se passer au niveau de la gauche et
que justement les gens ne veulent pas ne
veulent surtout pas qu'on leur impose ce
qu'ils aient a effectivement à voter on
peut parler effectivement des sondages
avant le avant le premier tour à votre
premier tour notamment
non je pense que il faut quand même
tenir compte de ce qui a été dit au
niveau des centristes parce que la
vocation de françois fillon de notre
guide pour l'élection présidentielle se
rend comme d'entendre toutes ses
sensibilités
et les sensibilités des centristes font
partie intégrante
à mon sens de la réussite future du
président fillon si on ne tient pas
compte ccp pendant toute sa campagne est
ce que disait un petit peu moins
françois fillon d'ailleurs
oui aujourd'hui les électeurs français
les électeurs ont tranché mais comme on
le redit c'était une compétition par un
combat le combat aujourd'hui c'est
d'aller gagner l'élection présidentielle
vous savez moi j'ai du sport dans une
équipe de football vous n'êtes pas
forcément toutes les mêmes des mêmes
personnalités en revanche n' a pas une
qui tient contre son camp l'objectif
c'est d'aller marquer un but de plus que
l'adversaire
et je pense qu'on est dans ce cadre là
et les sensibilités convient d'entendre
comme celle des jeunes comme encore une
fois les classes populaires qui votent
beaucoup
il va falloir les entendre et si c'était
le cas alors moi je me fais aucun souci
s'il y avait un clivage qui était fait à
ce niveau là ce que je ne crois pas pour
ça que je on leur parlera peut-être tout
à l'heure mais des gens comme le
président gérard larcher sont pour moi
des gens idéaux pour avoir la capacité à
nous rassembler à mettre de l'huile dans
les rouages avec la rondeur premier
ministre à moi et c'est bon mais moi je
voulais que vous avez déclaré quelques
heures après la victoire vous l'écrit
aujourd'hui mois flora sabah est votre
sentiment sur ces jeunes udi qui sont
tentés et plus que tenté à soutenir
emmanuel macron par exemple j'ai cru
comprendre que c'étaient pour le moment
des initiatives locales et qui avait
aucune directive de la part du bureau
national donc à voir s'il ne se retrouve
pas dans le programme de françois fillon
soit après j'ai envie de dire nous on va
rester sur nos positions on n'a pas
l'intention de changer parce que les
jeunes udi vont soutenir
emmanuel macron et après la compétition
se fera sur les idées mais j'ai envie de
dire pour l'instant et on a en plus des
alliances avec lui dit au niveau
national et au niveau des investitures
donc pour le moment j'ai envie de dire
pas besoin d' accorder plus de crédit
que cela il ya un autre candidat
néanmoins dont on n'a pas parlé au
centre c'est françois bayrou qui
pourrait éventuellement gênés ou non la
droite
pour la suite je voudrais revenir sur
sur sur lui dit
on pourra y déjeune unis mais joël
jouanneau la barre même de l'élection de
bayal souhaitez quand même quelques
ajustements ja il ya un mois en mai
belle famille
ces sales blancs il ya un mois tout le
monde disait françois fillon c'était le
candidat de la tolérance avec 1 1
un bouquin un livre faire je crois un
programme extrêmement sérieux
fantastique très bon candidat quand il
était de 8% à 10%
et puis bizarrement effets pervers de la
de la primaire il est devenu le méchant
loup et forcément ça a des conséquences
sur la jeunesse
et voilà c'est pas sérieux lui dit a
pris des positions tout à fait normale
concernant concernant la primaire la
primaire de droite
il faut savoir que françois fillon s'est
adressé dans cette primaire plutôt un
électorat droite même s'il ya eu des
électeurs à gauche mais son programme
des primaires ne sera probable sera
probablement celui des présidentielles
mais il y aura peut-être une petite
musique différente et on adaptera nous
adapterons il adaptera son programme en
fonction bien sûr des sensibilités qui
vont arriver
le corps électoral des présidentielles
c'est pas le collège électoral d'une
primaire donc forcément s'adresse quand
on s'adresse à 4 millions de personnes
ne s'adresse pas à 40 millions de
personnes donc forcément ça tout ça ça
va ça va bouger
forcément et j'en reviens à ma question
concernant françois bayrou est ce que ça
poserait un souci une déclaration de
candidature sachant qu'il manquerait
aussi qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure
quand même quelques voix que ce soit à
gauche mais à droite aussi dit pose
problème aux deux formations plus de
françois bayrou a voté françois hollande
en 2012
aujourd'hui de nouveau une proposition
s'il est candidat et en fonction de ses
déclarations de ces derniers jours une
proposition de nouveau contre contre la
droite et contre le centre une très
grande partie du centre françois bayrou
fait exactement le même jeu tous les
cinq ans il des ressorts il rentre dans
la vie politique tous les cinq ans une
anecdote karl olive de vous faire réagir
en tant que soutien d'alain juppé ancien
soutien d'alain juppé
discussions avec françois bayrou je
pense qu'il urgence à ce que françois
fillon puisse rencontrer les différents
interlocuteurs lieu ce soient les
représentants du lit parce que ce que ce
que disait flora tout à l'heure et est
important quand même par rapport à à ces
jeunes de l'udps et n'oublions pas que
les accords au niveau des législatives
et ce type de propos peut remettre aussi
quand même en question par rapport à
cela
donc il est urgent que le président
fillon aujourd'hui puissent rencontrer
ses interlocuteurs y compris françois
bayroux parce qu'à un moment donné c'est
les positions ne sont pas claires il
faut effectivement en tenir compte
maintenant qu'est ce qu'on a qu'est-ce
qu'on a noté aux municipales aux
législatives et aux régionales c'est que
nous avons remportés ces séquences
électorale parce que nous étions
rassemblés et rassembler dès le premier
tour
c'est la clé du succès donc il faut
faire un maximum d'efforts pour pouvoir
partir rassemblée sinon forcément ça va
effriter le décor avant même le premier
tour et donc on va réveiller
on va réveiller une gauche qui était
totalement lapidée c'est ce qui vient de
se passer est donné un champ à 1
emmanuel macron qui est particulièrement
intelligent qui fait le sillon sur les
terrains qui a beaucoup de réseaux
derrière lui et cas à mon sens un
discours qui est cohérent et qui va
effectivement dans le droit chemin de ce
que disait notamment les jeunes de
l'union smic soit vous vous n'avez pas
soutenu le candidat normalement si vous
étiez en charge de l'organisation à prix
appliqués à moi même une obligation de
réserve
mais aujourd'hui alors qu'elles rentrent
à mes fonds quelle est votre position
aujourd'hui est votre regard sur le
social je voudrais ajouter si rappelez
quand même qu'il s'agissait d'une
primaire ouverte de la droite et du
centre
donc cette volonté de rassembler la
haute autorité l'avait dès le départ
lorsqu'on a institué cette primaire pour
rassembler le plus large électorat de
droite possible et du centre ça me
semble quelque chose de fondamental donc
pour moi le candidat qui est sorti
aujourd'hui triomphalement j'allais dire
des urnes françois fillon a la capacité
pour rassembler comme le dit fort
justement karl évidemment là il s'était
adressé à un public de sa famille
politique de droite et du centre il va
falloir évidemment qu'il s'ouvre plus
largement puisqu'on sait que le succès
aux présidentielles vient du
rassemblement le plus large
du plus large possible donc c'est à lui
maintenant j'allais dire et à l'équipe
qui est autour de lui de trouver les
mots qui feront qui feront flèche de
tout bois j'allais dire pour pour
sensibiliser cet électorat qui n'a
peut-être pas voter spontanément pour
lui au 1er et au et au second tour de
cette élection
mais s'il me semble important c'est que
cette volonté de rassemblement
nous l'avions dès le départ dans le
cadre de l'organisation des primaires
c'était pas l'organisation des prix mais
pour les républicains
non nous avons voulu l'ouvrir puisque
nous savons pertinemment que remporter
les présidentielles et bien il faut
l'élargir très largement et très au delà
de sa famille politique et la primaire
de la gauche qui s'organise un pendant
ce temps qui les choses s'accélèrent
même avec le renoncement de l'auto
françois hollande et c'était c'était
jeudi jeudi soir premier le 1er décembre
la gauche qui s'organisent les candidats
qui sont sur le terrain notamment dans
le département des yvelines arnaud
montebourg par exemple était à maurepas
il y a quelques jours le sujet de
nicolas d'andry libérer la volonté
d'entreprendre des français c'est le
message martelé par arnaud montebourg
lors de sa visite à maurepas
pour cette rencontre le candidat à la
primaire de la gauche a choisi une salle
de sport ouverte il ya quatre ans par
yann namotte cet entrepreneur a connu
des difficultés pour monter son
entreprise tout comme sammy joola
fondateur d'une start-up dans le domaine
médical qui quand il parle d'avoir des
actions auprès des banques parce que les
banques soient enfin en service du
du meuble au service des autres des
entrepreneurs oui bien sûr aujourd'hui
comme je l'expliquais j'ai besoin de
2000 euros pour réparer mon chauffage
alors que mes comptes vont bien que je
peux voilà la banque ne veux pas me
prêter alors que c'est son job
aujourd'hui la boc de prêter l'argent
prêté de l'argent quand on en a ça n'a
pas de sens aujourd'hui on est à se
fixer parce que il ya aucune banque qui
prend un risque
alors cessons c'est le métier d'une
banque de prendre un risque à un moment
donné quand on a un projet face à ces
témoignages
arnaud montebourg met en avant certains
points de son programme économique
je propose qu au contraire on libère les
français d'un certain nombre de
contraintes d'inutiles moins de
réglementations moins de taxes qui
pèsent sur la vie quotidienne
je voudrais aussi créé une banque
d'encouragement au risque qui
cautionnerait le crédit bancaire pour
tous ceux qui n'acceptent pas au
financement sous la signature de l'état
ça permettrait de débloquer le système
bancaire les scrutins de la primaire de
la gauche se dérouleront le 22 et 29
janvier 2017
aujourd'hui on a le sentiment et c'est
même ce que ce qui ressort des sondages
qu'il est admis que la gauche ne sera
pas présente au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle qu'on
assistera à un duel entre françois
fillon et marine le pen est ce que ça
peut être malgré tout un handicap pour
la campagne de françois fillon suzanne
blanc de partir dans cette position de
favori aujourd'hui est déjà qualifié
pour le second tour et déjà même
président ça peut être pour sa campagne
j'aime pas du tout ce genre de
perspective
non c'est vrai je n'aime pas du tout
parce que ça peut démotiver démobilisés
et puis on a vu ce que les sondages ne
pouvait construire
donc voilà donc les françaises ont
déconstruit les sondages
donc on n'en est pas là la gauche
prépare ces primaires c'est bien et nous
on va continuer voilà et puis on verra
bien et puis si la marine le pen et
françois fillon au deuxième tour eh bien
on verra bien aussi voilà mais pour vous
est ce que la gauche aujourd'hui est
d'ores et déjà condamné parce que par
exemple de flora sabbagh ce sera écouté
pour le moment je pense que la gauche
elle est tout simplement inaudible après
on va voir ce qui ressort des primaires
de la gauche
si la gauche arrive à faire émerger un
nouveau candidat avec des propositions
qui parlent davantage aux français je
veux dire ne jettons pas pour le moment
les dés tout peut très vite évoluer en
politique
donc on va voir surtout si c'est un
armement de boer qui ressort de la
primaire de la gauche qui prendra je
pense sur le plan économique certaines
idées à marine le pen est donc dans ce
cas là on retombera dans un clivage
droite gauche
donc ne nous fions pas trop vite aux
sondages attendons un petit peu et on
verra ce qu'il advient dans les jours et
les mois qui philippe benassaya vous
préférez ce clivage gauche droite ou à
un clivage droite extrême droite
personne ne peut prévoir ce qui va se
passer dans six à sept mois personne je
vous rappelle qu'en 1995 edouard
balladur dû être président de la
république en 2002 etc
2009cet ségolène royal etc personne ne
peut prévoir ce qui va se passer donc la
gauche n'a pas perdu elle n'a pas encore
commencé à se battre
donc il faut il faut il faut attendre ce
qui est très intéressant par contre
c'est qu'on va avoir vraiment dé gauche
cette fois ci il va y avoir vraiment
plusieurs courants intéressant a
forcément une clarification au rayon
clarification idéologique à gauche il y
aura d'un côté peut-être ce centre dont
on parle un peu centre gauche hors
clivage qui serait incarnée par macron
une gauche plus tôt social-démocrate
talât
ala manuel valls une bulle gauche de la
gauche avec montebourg est un monde
c'est un débat qui commence à gauche
c'est un non combat comme ils disent
donc c'est vrai qu'il faudra attendre ce
qui se passe voilà maintenant on a connu
déjà on a connu déjà en 2002 une
confrontation droite extrême droite
on a connu une mobilisation entre les
deux tours on a connu tout ça je fais
confiance à landerneau médiatique pour
faire monter tout ça en fait remonter
tous entre les du tour on a connu tout
ça nous on est focalisé sur notre
programme on est focalisé sur notre
candidat je pense qu'il ya un grand
besoin d'alternance dans ce pays très
très grand besoin d'alternance
voilà laissons la gauche organiser les
soins la gauche organisé une de très
bonnes primaires parce qu'il faudra être
au niveau de la primaire de la droite
mais cette pression de 4 millions
d'électeurs la gauche lors de mulhouse
avait mobilisé à travers la france un
peu plus de deux millions c'est c'était
la moitié mais c'était la première fois
aussi lier 6,7 cette habitude de
primaire qui s'est installée aujourd'hui
concernant le programme justement est-ce
qu'il va y avoir et ce qu'il doit y
avoir une adaptation en fonction du
candidat qui va ressortir de la gauche
ben moi je dirais que en tant que
porte-parole d'alain juppé et soutiens
de la première heure j'aimerais
retrouver un peu plus de sensibilité
dans l'est dans les prochains mois dans
le dans l'équipe de françois fillon que
je retrouve pas aujourd'hui mais on est
au lendemain de l'élection de françois
fillon je pense que c'est à tort
important de bien intégrer toutes les
sensibilités
par rapport à ce que ce que disait
philippe c'est que moi je suis pas trop
inquiet pardon de le dire par rapport à
l'état de la gauche plus ou très
inquiets par rapport à la vitalité
pardon de le dire de l'extrême droite
mais pas seulement en france de ce qui
se passe en europe et de ce qui se passe
dans le monde
le sens de l'histoire la grèce
l'angleterre les etats-unis moi je pense
qu'il faut avoir un discours très clair
pour faire barrage au front national
sinon ce qui s'est passé le sens de
l'histoire il est dévastateur sur les
séquences on l'a vu sur des séquences
électorale dont on parle parfois de
vagues bleues dont on parle d'au dessus
d'amis rouge bon c'est rarement arrivé
mais voilà eu des vagues comme sa route
donc moi je suis plus inquiet et je
pense qu'il faut vraiment adapté le non
pas le programme de françois fillon mais
est vraiment derrière françois fillon
comme un seul homme
sinon il ya un vrai danger du front
national dans ce pays qui eût pu dire à
la veille des élections aux états unis
que le bon trump allait sortir gagnant
franchement aidé à qui sont endormis
avec hillary clinton dans la tête et qui
sont avec le trompe le matin ça fait pas
le même et faire savoir qu'à chaque
expérience de gauche excusez moi chaque
expérience du gauche en europe
il y à une vague extrêmement hâte mais
dans l'histoire aussi si on remonte dans
le xxème siècle à chaque expérience de
gauche il y à une vague d'extrême droite
et le barrage à cette extrême droite
excusez moi c'est la droite c'est pas la
gauche c'est la droite qui peut faire
barrage à l'extrême droite même si
pendant 25 ans 30 ans nous a dit même
discours droite extrême droite même
fonds baptisé d'un c'est faux ça c'était
la meilleure défense c'est l'attaqué
donc mais le vrai barrage à l'extrême
droite ça la droite à la gauche
du côté du front national justement on
n'imagine pas forcément que françois
fillon soit au second tour écoutez
françois simeoni c'est le président du
front national dans le département et
puis juste après écoute et aussi la
réaction de sandrine granby responsables
du ps dans le département des yvelines
des réactions qui ont été recueillis au
lendemain de la victoire de françois
fillon lors de la primaire selon le
candidat ultra libérale qui porte ce
projet de le cas ce n'est jamais
d'injustice sociale parce que regarder
par exemple l'augmentation de la tva de
deux points qui prévoit qui ça va
toucher ça va bien plus riches et les
plus humbles
à côté de ça il suffire unicef donc
véritablement nous on porte un projet
patriotes radicalement en opposition
avec ce candidat du système
les élections sont encore suffisamment
longtemps pour qu'il puisse avoir des
changements et c'est pas du tout fluo
moi je n'imagine pas du tout comme
certains le fait que une personne comme
si les monsois soit au deuxième tour
dans les périodes de tours nantes il y a
des règles il ya des des valeurs qui
sont les nôtres qui doivent être notre
boussole et je pense que c'est la seule
manière de de trouver le meilleur
d'entre nous le meilleur candidat pour
affronter une droite qui est de plus en
plus réactionnaire sur le plan sociétal
et qui est quand même très très libéral
sur le plan économique
donc voilà on a des primaires on ad d un
débat qui un cadre qui va s'organiser
il faut juste de respecter nos règles et
tu as mon avis c'est la meilleure façon
qu'il n'y ait aucune contestation et que
la dynamique de rassemblement et soit la
dernière
je considère que que ça soit alain juppé
ou françois fillon ou nicolas sarkozy on
aurait eu de toute façon un programme
très à droite mais là il est
particulièrement en opposition frontale
avec tout ce que l'on porte à gauche et
au parti socialiste
je reviens tout d'abord sur ce qui a été
dit par le par le front national
effectivement françois fillon qui sera
pas au second tour vous n'y pensez même
pas j'imagine pas les instruments de
palets les sondages d'aujourd'hui
l'adversaire pour le centre et la droite
pour françois fillon se situe où se
situe à gauche situe à l'extrême droite
et 2 et vous préférez quel adversaire
négative de voir tout ce qu'on souhaite
c'est la victoire de françois fillon
vraiment rester avec les qualités de
toute l'équipe qui qui l'entourent parce
que je pense que c'est un gage et on l'a
vu de légitime de légitimes pouvoir pour
effectivement mené à mener un
quinquennat pour les reconstruire tout
ce qui a été déconstruit pendant cinq
ans avec le résultat qu'on vient
d'obtenir jeudi dernier de la part du
président la république c'est une
première à cinquième république est la
clé du succès le point de programmes
particulièrement qui va peser si je fais
un petit tour de table savoir ce que
vous vous attendez avant tout du
candidat françois fillon le point de
programme le plus important pour vous
aujourd'hui karl olive le rassemblement
le rassemblement parce que alain schmitt
le disait à juste titre la victoire de
françois fillon à la primaire est une
victoire qui a permis d'engranger plus
de 4 millions de votants
la victoire de françois fillon qu'on
souhaite tous autour de cette table
à l'issue de la présidentielle ça sera
bien plus que 4 millions donc des gens
qui n'ont pas forcément ni l'habitude
d'aller voter ni qui parfois ne vote pas
forcément à droite là ils vont voter
pour un candidat qui re leur ressemblera
et ce candidat doit être le candidat de
la france multicolore multi facettes
avec un programme engagé et vu ce
trophée son histoire d'un gramme
peut-être c'est ça que j'entendais
parler aujourd'hui le kent quel est le
point de programme le plus important ça
va porter sur l'éducation sur la
sécurité sur nos entendu françois
hollande lorsqu'il a fait sa déclaration
de non candidature dire qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une situation dramatique
pour le pays avec cette menace
terroriste et qui voulait aussi vais
pouvoir exercer jusqu'au bout son mandat
est consacrée aussi à ça donc ça va ça
va se jouer sur quoi cette pour moi le
plein de programmes c'est la république
et la république c'est effectivement
notre identité avec des règles mais au
sein desquelles tout le monde peut
effectivement se retrouver et les règles
elles sont pas là pour être interprété
elles sont là pour être appliquée au
point de programmes suzanne blanc qu'est
ce qui vous semble le plus important
aujourd'hui
moi je dirais le point économique pour
redynamiser le pays sans pour autant
dramatiser comme ça là comme ça a été
fait au long de cette campagne par des
gens extérieurs bien sûr de la famille
de notre famille politique
donc ça par contre il va falloir être
très pédagogue par rapport à tout ça
vient d'expliquer qu'on n'est pas dans
un dans un mélodrame on est là pour
remettre le pays en marche
faire que nos enfants est un bel avenir
c'est surtout ça parce que là c'est vrai
qu'il ya une morosité tels que voilà
donc en a suscité tellement d'espoir les
et puis il ya aussi oui le problème la
question d'éducation est extrêmement
importante
extrêmement importante c'est le secteur
dont je suis en charge à montigny depuis
des années est vraiment c'est parce que
c'est depuis des années que je peux voir
avec le recul ce qui se passe et ce qui
ne va plus et nous enseignants n'en
peuvent plus c'est pas une question de
nombre d'enseignants c'est une question
de deux malheureusement ces enfants et
ces familles qui ces familles qui parte
à vau l'eau
ces familles qui n'est dupe plus leurs
enfants
cette violence qui règne compris chez
les tout-petits et donc ça il faut que
ça cesse et là effectivement il y a
vrai défi à relever un vrai défi à
relever et c'est pas en créant des
postes c'est autre chose il faut
remettre là les choses vraiment à plat
l'économique bien sûr mais je dirais
aussi le social
trop souvent on a reproché à la droite
d'avoir une vision uniquement
gestionnaire de la politique je pense
que la politique c'est aussi avoir une
vision d'avenir sur le projet de société
qu'on veut amener mais je dirais surtout
la jeunesse quel projet pour la jeunesse
parce que françois hollande avait promis
de réenchanter la france de provenir de
pots d'amener un avenir meilleur à la
jeunesse et aujourd'hui la genèse est
complètement désemparé la jeunesse a été
à l'oublier de ce quinquennat et
j'espère que françois fillon va réussir
ce grand enjeu clé la jeunesse et
aujourd'hui on sait qu'un candidat qui a
la jeunesse avec lui c'est un candidat
qui gagne les élections
françois hollande aura laissé la france
dans un état catastrophique une france
divisée
nous france abîmée cassé en panne
économiquement tout est à refaire tout
est à refaire le discours du bourget est
très très loin mon ennemi c'est la
finance
le réenchantement de la france enfin
tout ça c'est des mots de nemo de
campagne la france est totalement à
l'arrêt donc cela il appartient à notre
candidat françois fillon non seulement
de relancer la machine
économiquement nous lutter contre le
chômage je rappelle qu'à mon avis l'un
des facteurs de d'abandon de renoncement
transformante c'est qu'il n'a pas réussi
à inverser la courbe du chômage
donc je pense que ça c'est le premier
point est le deuxième point là je suis
d'accord avec karl
je pense qu'il faut rassembler les
français pensent qu'on est extrême
tourné dans une tension sociétale est
extrêmement importante
il lui aussi mettre en valeur nos
convictions de droite également c'est à
dire notre vision qu'on a de la
république du rassemblement de la
liberté de l'égalité et de la fraternité
et ça c'est très très important pour
nous de remettre ces valeurs là au coeur
de la société française pas
l'égalitarisme pas le communautarisme
pas tout ça voilà tout ça ça nous a
amené aux divisions ça nous amener tout
ce qu'on a conduit ce qui est important
c'est de remettre les valeurs
la république il remettre des valeurs de
la france au coeur du projet société de
france aviez vraiment qui n'a pas été
pour prononcer ici autour de cette table
c'est le retour de la confiance
les français n'ont plus confiance en eux
mêmes ils ont plus confiance en l'avenir
ils n'ont plus confiance en la fonction
présidentielle et nous sommes
fondamentalement que ce changement
d'hommes portés par cet élan populaire
extraordinaire sans précédent au sein de
notre famille de la droite et du centre
puis symboliser cette confiance et
attirer à nous j'allais dire tout un
électorat nouveau cette confiance je
pense que nous sommes tout à fait à même
avec françois fillon de la concrétiser
dans les faits et de pouvoir faire
avancer la france tant dans le domaine
économique que dans le domaine sociétal
ça me semble être tout à fait
fondamentale donc si j'avais un conseil
à donner à toute l'équipe qui est autour
de françois fillon il faut que celui-ci
continue à creuser son sillon avec
beaucoup de sérénité parce que je suis
sûr que c'est cette sérénité qui était à
lui une majorité d'électeurs
merci beaucoup à tous les 5 c'est la fin
de cette édition du 7 8 politique
consacré donc au lendemain de cette
primaire de la droite et du centre le
prochain 7,8 politique ce sera dans une
quinzaine de jours
depuis le parlement européen vous en
avez l'habitude en alternance avec cette
édition yvelines et nicolas qui rit le
vide sera entouré des eurodéputés très
bonne soirée
[Musique]